th
いいいいいい打球2
今日は外れ社長ですはいという技ですね
なんとか素隠居に来てラインタイプを12成果が出たと思いますそもそもなんで
引っ越したかっていうことを褒めると家に出場者さと知らない人が来るのが怖くて怖く
て引っ越しあるんですけどもすっごく発表です
新しい心境に来て今のところ視聴者さんが来たところはいい
一人です
万ナノなんでくるわけなんで来るかわかんないんですけどてがどこにその情報がある
かっていう訳わかんないんですよ
結構リアルに迷惑してるから本当にはやめてくださいーの
ありゃ何をヒントにどうやって俺ん家を特定して大取るの部屋まで特定したらわかん
ないんですけども
なんで苦しいお茶の動画で言ったよ動画で言ったからね目
アクセルで来ないで下さいに来ても何もしませんと言ってもまたくる人がいるからいい
ですよ
特定してもどこかは買ってもいいんですけど規定も僕は何も対応しませんマット枚もし
ないし何かひどいこととか凍り従っ体験爪はかかるようなことをしているともう早速
通報するんではじめの家は買った後加工喜んでいいんですけどもうちょっと5分色でも
僕も何もしません
人生に迷惑なのでやめてくださいちょっとねビビっては自分でもまあ間近っていう感じ
ですまたくるか的な
天神店引っ越さという方もう毎年恒例のアレです
質問コーナーですみた生えた時ってこんな痛いの誰かた迫
会社愚痴言いたくねえっ
うわぁこれ遺体はん
ステビュー質問を受け付けております僕に流す積もっとか構内で聞きたいこととか
アドバイスとかこれクエストとかなんかもうなんでもいいんだよ
何かあったらこの動画がコメント等の方に書いてください
でるからこの後ビルからここらへん早いわな
こんな気持ちで叩かれてるんだよ的にコメントを待つしてるんでこの動画のコメント欄
に何かこうをどんどん変えちゃってください
前場つかな無理なんですけどまぁなんとかこうピックアップして打つかの動画質問に
答えようと思いますライドね質問コーナー好評なんですよに行ってくれという声もいい
ですと定期的に又野
を買っております新生活に慣れてきたんですけども早くも早くも魔の手がちょっと伸び
てきてるんで
微妙ですじゃあコメントはお待ちしておりマースコンドームのコメントなんです
じゃあな
ちょっと勘弁してをする
んっん
r
えっ